Salaam alaikum peace be with you time to
leave everything put it to the side
whatever you're doing it's time to take
a break with the Quran the verbatim word
of god and i got a special person here
sheikh mustafa who's gonna share a
special aya with us along Lake oh sure
how are you like I said I'm handle I'm
doing great can you please go ahead and
share because they're taking a break now
they're leaving off everything yes now
it's time to reflect on again some
reflect over here are some two verses of
the Quran which really hard hitting I
like to reflect upon law says our mm in
shape on the regime kunlun of sin the
airport will mode button to a phone juju
rakuyo mal que llaman famines ahana nari
Woodhill elgin at hillel Janata fahad
affairs well hiya to dunya allama tururu
what that means is that everyone will
taste death and you shall only be paid
fully for your reward on the Day of
Resurrection and whoever is removed far
away from the fire and is made to enter
the garden of paradise that person has
indeed attained what they set out for
and the life of this world is nothing
but a provision of fulfilling your
desires and that's really a big reminder
for me in the next verse la tavola one
nephi my lucuma and fussy kumoi lettuce
my own nominal adina jewel kit eminent
men cabela kumoi min allah dina Sharaku
as an Cathy raw wine toast Bureau whatta
pufa in the lake Amin Osman more what
that means is you shall certainly be
tried concerning your wealth and
concerning yourself and you're
definitely gonna hear from those people
who've been given the book before you
and those people who associate partners
with Allah a lot of harm a lot of
difficult things to hear and if you're
patient and you protect yourself against
harm surely this is one of the affairs
which has been which
one of the best things you could
possibly do beautiful you can be going
through whatever hardship whatever
trauma drama but you know busy with life
and all these other dilemmas but then
you take a break with the Quran you here
in I it just puts things back in
perspective what are we living for we're
living for the pleasure of the crater of
a law I'm going to leave this life
behind soonerlater so connect with the
Book of Allah the Quran subscribe if you
haven't already we'll see you next time
Salaam alaikum tell us a lot shake like
a missile I'm gonna hunt a la Luna see
you there you [ __ ] mouth